David Boder: [In English] Spool 9-130A. Dina and Wanda Linik, L-I-N-I-K. In Russian. November the 7th, 1950. Boder.
David Boder: Paris, September the 13th, in eh...France September the 13th 1946. Hénonville, 50 kilometers from Paris in a home for displaced Jews, eh, eh, which is occupied by a kibbutz and also by a yeshiva. The interviewee is a Mrs. Dina Linik, em which is withholding her husband’s name, and she is going to report on her experiences, during the war in, which she had in, which she passed in Russia and then in [unintelligible] Poland.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну да...Also Мадам Линик, вы мне, пожалуйста, скажите, где вы были, когда началась война, и что с вами случилось во время войны, и как вы попали сюда. Ну...
Dina Linik: Война 1941 года...с немцами застигла меня в городе Киеве вместе с моей семьей и...которая состояла из мужа и двое дочерей, Софьей и Вандой. В июле сорок первого года, когда немец стал подступать близко к Киеву, я вместе с мужем и с детьми э-э-э...эвакуировалась э-э-э...на Северный Кавказ.
David Boder: Из Киева?
Dina Linik: Из Киева.
David Boder: Что русские правительства эвакуировали людей...свободно?
Dina Linik: Эвакуировала с детьми...эвакуировала на Северный Кавказ.
David Boder: А как мужа вашего не взяли?
Dina Linik: Подождите еще, дойдет [unintelligible].
David Boder: Так.
Dina Linik: Там мы прожили два с половиной месяца...где э-э-э...мужа...муж был взят в армию. В сентябре 1941 года муж ушел на фронт, и я осталась с двумя дочерьми. Сказать, сколько лет?
David Boder: Да.
Dina Linik: Одной, старшей, Софье 13 лет, а младшей Ванде 6 лет.
David Boder: Когда было?
Dina Linik: [short pause]
David Boder: [unintelligible]
Dina Linik: 5 лет. Пробыли мы на Северном Кавказе 4 месяца, и обратно Гитлер нагнал нас. Он стал подходить подступом Ростова и дальше Ростова начал подходить к Кавказу. Тяжело мне пришлось, когда на Северном Кавказе никак нельзя было с детьми выбраться, эвакуироваться, потому что местные власти очень сильно, много причиняло вредительства...и очень много...очень много, значит, ставило палки в колеса, чтобы не эвакуироваться и чтобы не уходить с этого...Кавказа.
David Boder: А куда же люди эвакуировались?
Dina Linik: С Кавказа люди не имели другого выхода, кроме в Каспийское море.
David Boder: То есть что значит?
Dina Linik: На...в Среднюю Азию, в Среднюю Азию.
David Boder: Ну и куда же, значит, что же тогда случилось?
Dina Linik: Что случилось? Приехали мы в Махачкала, это порт возле Каспийского моря.
David Boder: Так.
Dina Linik: Десятки тысяч людей валялись на пристани, на улице.
Dina Linik: Тяжелая картина была тогда, очень тяжелая картина еврейская. Люди по 6–7 недель валялись на пристани под дождем...
David Boder: А кто эти люди были, главное?
Dina Linik: Евреи.
David Boder: Почему евреи?
Dina Linik: Потому что за ними Гитлера было специально же известно на евреев всех погромы...
David Boder: Ага, и евреи хотели эвакуироваться.
Dina Linik: И потому евреи хотели эвакуироваться. Везде, все порты, все пристани были только завалены семьями, детьми еврейскими.
David Boder: Да.
Dina Linik: После долгих мытарств я попала на...на пароход, если можно назвать его пароход, это был не пароход, а какой-то транспортный...
David Boder: . . . баржа...
Dina Linik: . . . транспортная баржа, которую так набили битком, что едва ли селедки бы так уместились в бочке, как...как людей уместили в этой барже в трюме, на палубе, везде.
David Boder: Так.
Dina Linik: Баржа была не при...как это сказать...ну, она не была приготовлена для...
David Boder: . . . для пассажиров...
Dina Linik: Да...для пассажиров, для такого груза...ну и кроме того...нужно прибавить к тому, что налетали очень часто самолеты...
David Boder: Откуда?
Dina Linik: Пытались...Самолеты залетали немецкие, пытались бомбить, бомбили нас по дороге. Это самое [unintelligible] получило незначительное повреждение...
David Boder: Так.
Dina Linik: . . . после чего начался сильный шторм, шестибалловый шторм. Нас качало в пароходе как игрушка все равно. Несколько раз мы уже мысленно прощались со своей жизнью. Всякие это...теснота, это самое переживания...сделали...многих людьми...многие люди получили свою смерть на этом самом пароходе.
David Boder: Что, так [unintelligible]?
Dina Linik: Да. Очень многие получили паралич сердца. Их не выдерживали этот самый режим, ну...
David Boder: Сколько [unintelligible] вы были на пароходе?
Dina Linik: Мы...тот пароход, который должен нас был перевезти за шестнадцать часов, мы были двое с половиной суток на...на море, на открытом море, после чего мы прибыли в Красноводск. В Красноводске начали размещать нас по эшелонам, транспортам в разные...разные части Средней Азии. Мы попали в колхоз возле Алма-Ата.
David Boder: Так.
Dina Linik: Там я прожила с детьми 9 месяцев.
David Boder: Ага. Что вы делали?
Dina Linik: Работала в колхозе.
David Boder: Что вы работали?
Dina Linik: Работала на поле в колхозе, на уборке хлеба, затем работала на консервном заводе, и много пришлось перетерпеть, пережить за это время.
David Boder: А что, платили за работу?
Dina Linik: За работу...Конечно, платили хлебом. Норму давали [unintelligible], мы были приноравлены ко всем колхозникам. Потом в сорок втором году я выехала обратно...да, в сорок втором году, сорок третий год и сорок четвертый год это все время я была в Средней Азии. Затем в сорок четвертом году, когда уже был взят город Киев, я обратно посредством [unintelligible] при содействии, так сказать, власти мне удалось получить разрешение вернуться обратно к себе на родину.
David Boder: В Киев?
Dina Linik: В Киев.
David Boder: А скажите, что дети делали в колхозе?
Dina Linik: Старшая работала и училась, а младшая училась в школе.
David Boder: Так. А в общем условия в колхозе были какие?
Dina Linik: Какие могли быть общие условия в колхозе...были одинаковы, как для всех.
David Boder: Да. Какие условия были? Хорошо было там жить или что?
Dina Linik: Хорошо было, если мы не видели близко Гитлера, уже было хорошо. Мы считали то хорошо, что несоприкосновенно, близко с Гитлером, это считалось хорошо. От Гитлера я уходила 4 раза, всякий раз он нас настигал.
David Boder: То есть какие 4 раза? Из Киева?
Dina Linik: В Киеве он нас настигал, в Северном Кавказе настигал, затем после Северного Кавказа, я забыла прибавить, я еще была в Грузии, там тоже он подходил близко, ну и затем я в Средней Азии, когда возвращалась, если вы помните, это обратно с Ростова он начал свой...свои успехи, и там тоже в дороге нас застало на этом...в Ростове, там тоже я еле-еле избавилась от следов этого Гитлера.
David Boder: Так-так.
Dina Linik: Ну затем...
David Boder: А от мужа вы слышали, письма получали?
Dina Linik: А от мужа...от мужа шел 3 сентября я получила от него 5 писем и после этого как в воду канул. Известно мне только, что он очутился под Полтавой, где он был...вся его дивизия была окружена немцами. Дальше о судьбе я его ничего не знаю. Я писала неоднократно в правительство, но мне ответили, что никаких следов, пропал без вести. Можно считать, что если бы он жив был, то он вернулся бы. Я считаю, что он погиб.
David Boder: А вы думаете, если бы он был жив, он мог бы вас найти теперь. Есть кто-нибудь в России, кто знает, где вы?
Dina Linik: Я его ждала в Киеве полтора года...и не могла его дождаться. Я считаю, что полтора года — достаточный срок для того, чтобы узнать что-нибудь за него или чтобы он о нас что-нибудь узнал, причем он же имел много знакомых, и близких, и родных, где бы он мог спросить о нас, если он жив.
David Boder: Так, они знают, где вы.
Dina Linik: Да. Теперь так. В Киеве я прожила полтора года.
David Boder: В Киеве?
Dina Linik: В Киеве.
David Boder: Это уже война кончилась или еще она продолжалась?
Dina Linik: Война была уже закончена.
David Boder: О! Вы вернулись в Киев в каком году?
Dina Linik: В сорок четвертом году.
David Boder: В сорок четвертом году немцев уже выгнали из Киева? Война закончилась в сорок пятом, и вы все еще жили в Киеве. Но как вы там жили в Киеве, с чего вы жили?
Dina Linik: В Киеве я работала.
David Boder: Где?
Dina Linik: Я работала, на фабриках работала, на заводе работала...
David Boder: Ну и каковы же были условия? Вы работали на фабрике, что вам платили?
Dina Linik: Что мне платили? Зарплату платили.
David Boder: Да. [unintelligible] можно было на это жить с двумя детьми?
Dina Linik: Нет. Я материально совершенно не была обеспечена, и мне очень тяжело пришлось. Одна прокормить детей я не могла. Дети заболели после всех этих мытарств, переживаний. Дети заболели и не были приспособлены и к тому, чтобы уже больше бороться с голодом, с этими недостатками. После этого, по репатриации, так сказать, польских граждан я попала в общие списки и выехала из Киева.
David Boder: Как полька?
Dina Linik: Как полька.
David Boder: А вы что, родились в Польше?
Dina Linik: Я родилась в Польше.
David Boder: Так.
Dina Linik: Выехала я с детьми из...попала я в город Краков, где я прожила короткое время, а затем на общих основаниях как...как получившая сообщение о своих близких Америки, Палестины...
David Boder: Кто у вас в Палестине?
Dina Linik: У меня в Палестине есть мать.
David Boder: О! Так.
Dina Linik: У меня в Палестине есть сестра и брат, которым удалось в двадцать втором году уехать к себе туда. Сейчас у меня сильное желание есть ехать в Палестину к своим родным, но известно, что по сложившимся обстоятельствам политическим я не могу сейчас уехать туда. Питаю надежду, что в скором будущем я сумею объединиться со своими ро...близкими, родными и устроить жизнь своих детей, чтобы он имел более благополучный исход, чем моя жизнь...
David Boder: Кто это он?
Dina Linik: Чтобы жизнь моих детей случилась более, чтоб исход, жизнь моих детей был более благоприятный, чем у меня сложилась в...жизнь моя.
David Boder: Так, вы говорите, вы хотите...А ваши сестры в Чикаго разве не говорят по-русски?
Dina Linik: Мои сестры уехали, я еще была совсем м...
David Boder: Маленькая.
Dina Linik: Маленькая.
David Boder: И вы не знаете, говорят ли они?
Dina Linik: Я их хорошо помню. Знают ли они русский язык, я сомневаюсь, потому что одна сестра Рахиль [unintelligible] находится 34 года в Чикаго. Вторая сестра находится с двадцать второго года в Чикаго.
David Boder: [In German]...Also wollen wir reden Jiddisch jetzt.
Dina Linik: . . . Wollen wir reden Jiddisch.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] אלזא לאמיר רעדן אידיש יעצט לאמיר רעדן אידיש
David Boder: עה, וואו זענט איר געקומען קיין פוילן, ווען איר זענט אוועק געפארן פון קיעוו?
Dina Linik: אויף, עה, מיר געקומען א פוילישע ??
David Boder: וואו, וואו זענט איר געקומען, צו וועלכער שטאט?
Dina Linik: קיין קראקוב.
David Boder: נאך קראקוב זענט איר געקומען?
Dina Linik: יא, נאכער האבן מיר געוואוינט אין לאדזש, אין קראקוב, אין קאטאוויץ, איז סאסנאוויץ, אויסגעפארן גאנץ פוילן, און
David Boder: און פון וואס האט מען דאס געלעבט?
Dina Linik: און, און מען האט געלעבט פון אלעס וואס די אמעריקאנער עה, מלוכה האט געשטיצט.
David Boder: יא, אלעס. און אייערע ווייבער און מיידלעך זענען געווען מיט אייך?
Dina Linik: יא. נאכער זענען מיר געקומען, אויכעט אלעס א דאנק די אמעריקאנער מלוכה, האט אונז געגעבן אזעלכע שטיצונג, אז מען האט געקענט איבערפארן פון פוילן קיין טשעכיי, ווייל אין פוילן איז אויכעט, אזוי ווי מען ווייסט די אלגעמיינע לאגע איז ניט קיין גוטע פאר די אידן, עס איז פארגעקומען אז מען האט זייער פיל געמארדעט אידן אין פוילן זענען מיר געווען
David Boder: האט איר זעלבסט געזען?
Dina Linik: אלץ האט מען געזען. יא. פאר מיר איז פארגעקומען ווי אין לאדזש האט מען געמארדעוועט פיר אידישע קיבוץ’ניקעס,
David Boder: יא, פארוואס?
Dina Linik: פאר גארנישט. דערפאר וואס זיי זענען אידן.
David Boder: אהא.
Dina Linik: מער ניט. נאר וואס, ווייל זיי הייסן אין דער נאמען איד. אלזא האט מען געזען אז פאר אונז איז אין פוילן איז אויך ניט קיין לעבן, ווייל די אידן לאזט מען ניט, לאזט מען ניט אין פוילן דאס לעבן, האט מען אונז געהאלפן, און דערנאך זענען מיר געקומען קיין טשעכיי
David Boder: יא.
Dina Linik: און אין טשעכיי האט די פראנצויזישע רעגירונג ערלויבט אז מען זאל אריין פארן אלס טראנזיטן, וועלכע צו פארן ווייטער, טראנזיט,
David Boder: אהא.
Dina Linik: יעצט געפינען מיר זיך אין ??, דאס הייסט אין קיבוץ פון אגודת פועלי ישראל
David Boder: אגודת וואס?
Dina Linik: אגודת פועלי ישראל
David Boder: פועלי ישראל
Dina Linik: פועלי ישראל, מיטן נאמען נצח ישראל
David Boder: אהא.
Dina Linik: דאהי געפינען מיר זיך שוין פיר מאנאט מיט דעם האפענונג אז אונז וועלן מיר אפפארן נאך ארץ ישראל
Dina Linik: ווילט זיך, איך האב זייע געוואלט זיך געוואלט זען מיט מיינע צוויי שוועסטער וועלכע זענען אין אמעריקע, אבער איך ווייס ניט ווי קען דאס קומען, צי קענען זי מיר אויף אזוי פיל העלפן אז איך זאל קענען פארן נאך אמעריקע?
David Boder: אהא, האבן זיי צו אייך געשריבן?
Dina Linik: איך האב ערהאלטן פון זיי בריוו, אבער זיי האבן מיך געפרעגט, אפשר, אפשר נייטיג זיך אין עפעס אבער פון דענץ, האבן זיי ניט, זיי ווייסן אז איך האב אין ארץ ישראל א שוועסטער מיט א ברודער א קלענערן, און אויך אין ארץ ישראל א מוטער
David Boder: יא
Dina Linik: אבער אלזא וואלט איך זייער געוואלט ??
David Boder: אהא. נא, פילייכט ווען איר גייט עס נאך ארץ ישראל, פאר אן אמעריקאנער איז דאך לייכט צו מאכן א וויזיטע דארטן?
Dina Linik: קיין אמעריקע?
David Boder: ניין, פון אמעריקע נאך פאלעסטינע
Dina Linik: יא.
David Boder: מען פארט דאך ??, עס וועט זיך בארואיגן, און זיי וועלן וויסן די גאנצע משפחה איז אין פאלעסטינע, וועלן זיי קומען נאכדעם?
Dina Linik: קיין פאלעסטינע?
David Boder: יא.
Dina Linik: פון אמעריקע?
David Boder: יא. מען פארט זייער אפט. מען פארט זייער פיל.
Dina Linik: עס קענען פון פאלעסטינע קיין אמעריקע פארן?
David Boder: א, נא. פון אמעריקע נאך פאלעסטינע
Dina Linik: ניין, און פון פאלעסטינע קיין אמעריקע?
David Boder: דאס איז, יעס, מען קען פארן נאטורליך, אבער אמעריקאנישע בירגער קענען דאך פארן פריי נאך פאלעסטינע, געווענליך
Dina Linik: איך מיין. איך ווייס ניט אז זיי קענע פארן, זיי זענען עלטערע צוויי פערזאן, ניט קיין אכצן יאר, און פארלאזן אייגענע פאמילע, און זענען פארנומען מיט זייערע געשעפטן, געשעפטליך
David Boder: אהא. און, זיינען ביידע טעכטער אייערע היער מיט אייך?
Dina Linik: יא.
David Boder: וואו האט איר זיך אנגעשלאסן אין דעם קיבוץ?
Dina Linik: אונז האמיר, אונז האמיר געקומען קיין פוילן האבן מיר זיך איינגעמעלדעט אין אגודה
David Boder: יא
Dina Linik: אין די אגודה, און די גאנצע צייט האלטן מיר זיך האנט ביי האנט מיט דער אגודה
David Boder: און זיי האבן אייך אריבערגעבראכט?
Dina Linik: יא. די אגודה האט אונז אריבער געבראכט פון פוילן קיין פראנקרייך, און ביז יעצט זעען זיי פונעם גאנצן שטיצן אונז, אז מיר זאלן קענען קומען קיין ארץ ישראל
David Boder: אהא, ווי זאגט מען דעס, איר, איר, וואס טוט איר היער א גאנצן טאג? און וואס טוען די קינדער? ווי אלט זענען די קינדער?
Dina Linik: יא. אין, אין דעם קיבוץ נצח ישראל לערנען זאך, אין ווערטשאפט, אין שניידערי
David Boder: מיט די, די ארטס ווערקשאפט
Dina Linik: יא. ארטס ווערקשאפט אין שניידעריי, אונטער דער, און דער לערערקע איז מדאדם, אה
David Boder: לאקשטיין
Dina Linik: אה, אלא לאקשטיין, ס’איז זייער א וואוילער, א אידישע, העפליכער מענטש, א גוטער לערערין פאר אונז, און זי זעט אז דער איד, זאל, זאל, יעדער אידיש קינד זאל באקומען עפעס א פאך און זאל קענען סובסיסטן אויף די גאנצע וועלט
David Boder: אהא. און די קינדער?
Dina Linik: און די קינדער מיינע. איין טאכטער איז נאך א קליינס, וואלדא, זי איז אלט צען יאר, און זי לערנט עברית אז זי וועט קומען קיין ארץ ישראל זאל זיך קענען אויסשמועסן מיט אלעמען, און די עלטערע טאכטער לערנט אויכעט עברית, און זי לערנט פאר גערטנעריי
David Boder: אהא, און זי וועט, זי וועט ארבייטן אין, אין ארץ ישראל אין א קאלאניע ווער
Dina Linik: וואס וועט, איך קען גארניט וויסן, וואס מיט אונז קען מען גיבן, אז מען קומט קיין ארץ ישראל. אבער מיר האפן אז מען קומט קיין ארץ ישראל און מען קען גערטנעריי, מען קען נייען, איז קען סובסיסטן, עפעס וועט מען דאך טוען זאל מען קענען באקומען א נוץ
David Boder: און וואו לעבט איר היער? האט איר א צימער פאר זיך??
Dina Linik: יא, אין אגודה, אין נצח ישראל, אין קיבוץ, האב איך איין צימער פאר מיר און מיינע צוויי טעכטער, און זיי באזארגן שוין מיט בעט געוואנט, מיט א בעט, און מיט שפייז, און מיט ווארימקייט, אלעס וואס סי, וואס סי קומט, אלעס, עה, און די אגודה, באזארגן זיי אלעס
David Boder: און אייערע שוועסטער האבן אייך נאך קיינמאל ניט געשיקט קיין באשטיצונג? קיין געלט?
Dina Linik: איך האב ניט געפאדערט, ווייל, איך, אונז זיינען דא ניט הונגעריק
David Boder: אהא.
Dina Linik: עס לעבט מען ניט אזוי שטארק, ווי זאגט מען
David Boder: אין לוקסוס
Dina Linik: אין לוקסוס. אלזא זענען מיר ניט הונגעריק, מיר האבן זיך זייער פיל אנגעליטן ביי דעם דייטש פאר דער קריג, אז מען געפינען שוין אויס, אז דא הייסט שוין, ווי הייסט עס, אז מען קען שוין שלאפן רואיג, און קיין נפקא מינא מיטן געוויר, און, און
David Boder: מיטן געווער.
Dina Linik: מיטן געווער. יא, און קיינער, און זי ווייסן אז דו שלאפסט ביינאכט אז דו שפילסט ניט מיטן לעבן, און מען שטייט אויף אינדערפרי און ס’איז פאראן א גלאז טיי, איז שוין, איז מען שוין מיט
David Boder: און וואו איז די ארבייט אין די קאכאזן האט מען זיך גוט באנומען? פריינטליך באנומען?
Dina Linik: ווי קען, וואס הייסט פריינטליך באנומען? ווי קען זיין פריינטליך? אז זיי קענען קומען נעמען דעם אידן, פרעג איך דיך
David Boder: נא פרעג איך אייך?
Dina Linik: מען קען נישט זאגן פריינטליך. אבער אלעס האבן זיי געהאט רעכט פאר דער מאכט, זיי האבן דאך מורא געהאט עפעס א געפיל, אבער צו דעם איד אדער קעגן דעם איד דאס האבן זיי ניט געקענט טון ווייל דאס איז, די מלוכה האט געקוקט אויף דעם, אבער פריינטליך ניט, זיי האבן געזאגט אז אידן דארפן פארן צו זוכן ארץ ישראל
David Boder: די קאכאזן האבן דאס געזאגט?
Dina Linik: יא. אז אידן דארפן פארשן צו זוכן א לאנד
David Boder: אהא. און וואס איז, אייער עלטערע טאכטער אה, זאגט איר, ווילט איר אז איך זאל זיי זען?
Dina Linik: יא, און געוואלט אינען זאלן איבער געבן א גרוס פאר מיינע שוועסטער
David Boder: נא, ברענגט אריין ביידע מיידלעך
David Boder: [In Russian] Как вас зовут, барышня?
Sophia Linik: Софья Линик.
David Boder: И вам сколько лет?
Sophia Linik: Девятнадцать.
David Boder: А у вас что, тетки в Париже, тетки в Чикаго?
Sophia Linik: Да, у меня две тетки в Чикаго.
David Boder: Как их зовут?
Sophia Linik: Рахиль и Гиту.
David Boder: А фамилий вы не знаете?
Sophia Linik: Я знаю.
David Boder: Как, Рахиль кто?
Sophia Linik: Рахиль Бравер...
David Boder: Так, и Гиту...
Sophia Linik: Гиту...Бухенлер.
David Boder: Гиту Бухенлер. А вы им написали письма...письма?
Sophia Linik: Мы писали письма.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] [unintelligible]
David Boder: [In Russian] Скажите по-русски, если вы не можете. А что они вам пишут?
Sophia Linik: Они пишут, что очень счастливы, что узнали о нас, так они давно о нас не имели сведений...
David Boder: Ага.
Sophia Linik: . . . так они давно не имели о нас сведения...ну, очень бы хотели нас увидеть.
David Boder: Ага. А что ваша сестра Ванда, сколько ей лет?
Dina Linik: Нашей Ванде 11 лет.
David Boder: [unintelligible]
Sophia Linik: [unintelligible]
David Boder: Понятно. Так, ей 10 лет. Она большая такая.
David Boder: Ну, а Ванда, как тебе тут нравится во Франции?
Wanda Linik: Хорошо.
David Boder: Очень хорошо. А кто эта маленькая девочка, которая с тобой всегда?
Wanda Linik: Это моя подруга.
David Boder: [unintelligible]
Wanda Linik: Моя подруга.
David Boder: Твоя подруга. А что ты целый день делаешь тут?
Wanda Linik: Играюсь.
David Boder: Играешься? А ты умеешь читать по-русски?
Wanda Linik: Умею.
David Boder: И писать по-русски умеешь?
Wanda Linik: Да.
David Boder: А что нужно сказать твоей тетке? Хочешь поехать в Америку?
Wanda Linik: Я хочу, чтобы она ко мне приехала.
David Boder: Так. А ты куда собираешься ехать?
Wanda Linik: В Палестину.
David Boder: Ну хорошо. А теперь спой песню.
Sophia Linik: Ну спой, спой.
David Boder: А что, вы хотите поехать в Америку?
Sophia Linik: Ну так....
David Boder: Ну, говорите, что хотите.
Wanda Linik: [laughing]
David Boder: Нет, это...
Dina Linik: Моя мама хочет в Палестину, а мое желание ехать в Америку.
Sophia Linik: Это она знает, что моя мама очень хочет ехать в Палестину и никуда больше, а мое желание ехать в Америку.
David Boder: А что вы умеете делать?
Sophia Linik: Что умею делать?
David Boder: Да. Вы какое-нибудь...
Sophia Linik: Например.
David Boder: . . . ремесло знаете?
Sophia Linik: Ну...я училась.
David Boder: Чему?
Sophia Linik: Я училась в мединституте.
David Boder: В каком институте?
Sophia Linik: В мединституте. Медицинский институт.
David Boder: И чему вы научились там?
Sophia Linik: Ну я ж не кончила его.
David Boder: А сколько лет вы имели его?
Sophia Linik: Я училась на первом курсе...и мне пришлось...да...на дантиста...на дантиста.
David Boder: А вы кончили гимназию?
Sophia Linik: Я кончила гимназию, поступила на первый курс мединститута, медицинского института...
David Boder: Так.
Sophia Linik: Ну и я занимаюсь на первом курсе на зубоврачебном факультете мне пришлось оставить.
David Boder: В каком городе вы были на зубоврачебном факультете?
Sophia Linik: В Киеве.
David Boder: В Киеве. Уже когда вы вернулись из Средней Азии?
Sophia Linik: Да, из Средней Азии, так как я в Киеве только и окончила гимназию.
David Boder: Ага...А вы своей тетке написали об этом?
Sophia Linik: Я написала ей маленькое письмецо [unintelligible] написала, потому что я не могу по-английски писать, а по-еврейски тоже.
David Boder: Тоже. Можете или не можете?
Sophia Linik: Не могу. Я по-еврейски немножко написала, потому что я не могу выразить здесь все, что я хочу написать.
David Boder: Так.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] [unintelligible]
Wanda Linik: [unintelligible]
David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-130A. Covering the interview with a whole family, Dina, Sophia, and Wanda Linik. At Hénonville, near Paris. November 7th 1950, Boder. The other half of this spool is eh...Pinkhus Rosenfeld.